[Musik]
mails mit den richtigen fragen an einem
wahlsonntag hierbei bild live ein
wichtiger wahlsonntag denn das wahrsagen
viele eine kleine bundestagswahl die
wahl im bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland
in nordrhein westfalen mit einem klaren
wahlsieg für die cdu an der
geschrumpften spd einer sehr stark
geschrumpften fdp und einer sehr stark
gewachsenen grünen partei darüber
diskutieren wir hier im studio bei bild
live machen das mit der journalistin
langjährigen taz redakteure früher
herrmann bei uns mit dem star
kolumnisten hans ole jörges mit jens
spahn dem cdu-mann und mit marcel luthe
der mann der selbst im abgeordnetenhaus
in berlin saß als politiker und jetzt
den politikern ganz besonders streng ja
ich würde sagen in sachen
parteienverdrossenheit
politikerverdrossenheit auf die finger
schaut ihnen allen schönen guten abend
herr jörges eine frage ganz klar am
anfang die spd geschrumpft dort in
nordrhein westfalen ist das auch kanzler
schuld auch ganz sicher aber nicht nur
der kanzler also die das bild das die
spd ihren der ampel koalition in berlin
abgibt ist verheerend im moment da wäre
nach dieser wahl dringend eine
kabinettsumbildung auf der spd-seite
notwendiges müssen raus die
verteidigungsministerin unter
gesundheitsminister doch da darf er gar
nicht warten bis der im nächsten herbst
wieder eine spur der verwüstung hinter
sich her zieht das muss er gerade ziehen
man hat gemerkt dass offensichtlich die
wähler auch in nrw die grünen quasi als
eine autonome kraft in der ampel
koalition wahrnehmen die haben ihren
kleinen kanzler dass es herr habeck und
die haben ihre außenministerin die beide
hervorragend ankommen und ansonsten gibt
es dann eben eine sehr gute verbogene
merkwürdige unfassbare spd und eine fdp
von der man sowohl im bund als auch in
nrw sagen muss die hat
unglücklicherweise die falschen ämter
übernommen den beiden regierungen und
zwar zwei ämter hat die ihnen gar nichts
bringen da finanzminister der ständig
schulden macht bringt der partei nichts
da gehen wir gleich noch mal tiefer in
die analyse und bleiben oder hermann
einmal bei der spd bei olaf scholz der
heute ja zum ersten mal schleswig
holstein konnte man noch so unter tisch
fallen lassen aber dann richtig bitteren
wahlabend erlebt die cdu deutlich
gewachsen und im moment sieht es nicht
so aus als würde die spd tatsächlich als
nummer zwei regieren können also also
sagt hans uli jörges da steckt richtig
viel olaf scholz auch drin in diesem
wahlergebnis also das kann ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt ich erkennen also es gibt
ja immer diese umfragen auch jetzt ganz
neue wie beliebt sind einzelne politiker
da ist sofort geschmiert olaf schon ein
er ist immer noch weit vorne also er ist
immer noch direkt hinter habeck und
hinter baerbock grund erste mio der ist
mittlerweile auch vor ihm ja genau also
die grünen sind freunde aber was jetzt
lindner zum beispiel ist weit weit
hinten im vergleich dazu also ich glaube
jetzt nicht dass man sagen kann das war
eine wahl gegen scholz sondern ich
glaube dass man gegen die spd ja auch
das nicht sondern ich glaube dass der
das problem war das haben wir auch die
umfragen gezeigt dass herr kutschaty der
spitzenkandidat der spd in nordrhein
westfalen die ich wirklich bekannt ist
obwohl der minister war aber hatte kein
wichtiges amt war justizminister
offenbar wussten die meisten gar nicht
weder ist und dann hat man natürlich
pech wenn man gegen den amtsinhaber
antritt also herr wüst hatte das den
wirklichen vorteil dass herr laschet
dann schon jetzt doch seit september
neuer beratern amtsbonus herr wüst im
ernst scheint sie das ernst dieser
blasser mann hatte einen amtsbonus er
jedenfalls war im amt und offenbar
beliebt und bekannt ist
jedenfalls ist es schwierig eine wahl zu
gewinnen wenn man gar nicht bekannt ist
im land und das soll das problem von
herrn kutschaty jetzt sitzt hier neben
ihnen neben mir ein wahlsieger heute
abend kommt ja auch aus
nordrhein-westfalen die ans sparen freut
sich heute richtig über diesen
wahlerfolg in nordrhein-westfalen nehme
ich mal an freut sich für hendrik wüst
und dann denkt man einmal nach und sagt
vielleicht läuft es doch nicht so gut
für die cdu in den nächsten tagen und
wochen dort in nordrhein westfalen den
die spd wir haben card thomas kutschaty
gehört der erhebt noch anspruch obwohl
er klar nummer zwei geworden ist
möglicherweise wollen die grünen auch
eine ampel machen und die fdp rutscht
dann knapp über die fünf prozent und
wollen auch eine ampel sind sie am ende
stehen sie mit leeren händen da also sie
haben recht ich freue mich und zwar
riesig über dieses war ergebnis das
wurde jetzt über wochen ein kopf an kopf
rennen vorhergesagt mann ist übrigens
erinnern vor ein paar monaten lagen wir
noch ziemlich hinten also es war ein
richtiger aufholjagd von henrik wüst von
dem team in nordrhein westfalen wo wir
alle in der cdu nrw auch jeder an seiner
stelle einfach mitgeholfen haben dass er
wirklich gute teamarbeit und man hat den
schwung echt in den letzten zwei drei
wochen noch mal gemerkt und 35% und es
scheint ja noch leicht hoch zu gehen das
glaube ich hätte vor zwei drei tagen
einfach niemand erwartet ist ein großer
erfolg so ist der neue hoffnungsträger
jetzt sie haben ja noch vorne täter
kommt es jetzt erstmal zu der frage was
da in nrw passiert es gibt zwei
wahlsieger die dazu gewonnen haben das
sind die cdu und die grünen
und das ist ja erstmal ein befund und
wissen sich halt noch zitate von olaf
scholz im ohr in elefantenrunden nach
der bundestagswahl man müsste doch
schauen welche parteien gewonnen haben
und welche parteien verloren haben und
das würde ja was für die
regierungsbildung sagen aber wenn er
jetzt bei der spd irgendwie also ich
verstehe dass man in diesem schock nach
diesem ergebnis jetzt irgendwie versucht
sich zu retten aber wäre nach dem
historisch schlechtesten ergebnis der
spd in nordrhein-westfalen in einem
ihrer zumindest früher mal stamm länder
jetzt noch eine regierungsbeteiligung da
ableiten will dem ist einfach nicht zu
helfen also ich würde mir da mal ein
bisschen demut empfehlen hannelore kraft
hat vor fünf jahren bei einem noch
besseren wahlergebnis als hertie aber
damals gesagt das ergebnis war so
schlecht ich übernehme verantwortung ich
trete zurück ich finde das müsste
eigentlich die debatte bei der spd in
nrw sein wie man nach diesem historisch
schlechten wahlergebnis überhaupt noch
vorsitz nach hinten könnte am ende
ungerecht für sie seien und könnten
trotzdem am ende mit leeren händen
dastehen wenn die grünen halt sagen wir
wollen hat nicht mit der cdu gut das
muss man jetzt abwarten in den
gesprächen in den nächsten tagen aber
wissen sie herr walter borjans der ist
ja aus nordrhein westfalen der ehemalige
spd-vorsitzende und er hat nach der wahl
im september die für uns bitter und hart
war gesagt man kann vielleicht als
zweiter versuchen irgendwie eine
mehrheit zu kriegen moralisch richtig
ist es deswegen nicht und jetzt muss die
spd ich meine ist alles mal acht monate
her jetzt muss die spd sich vielleicht
auch mal an dem messen lassen was sie
dafür alisch das nicht in ordnung dass
würden sich zu eigen machen moralisch
wäre das nicht in äußerst einfach
gegenüber den wählern nicht in ordnung
ich meine die haben ein ziemlich klares
votum heute ausgesprochen sie wollen
dass hendrik wüst ministerpräsident
bleibt und zwar deutlicher
als das manch einer erwartet hat in den
letzten tagen sie haben cdu und grünen
zu wahlsiegern gemacht für nordrhein
westfalen und das ist für mich jetzt
zumindest mal erst mal die erste logik
dass dort die gespräche auch miteinander
geführt werden und wie gesagt ich würde
ja spd jedenfalls mal empfehlen auch als
jemand der in echt bitteren wahlabend
erlebt hat letztes jahr im september und
wir haben an diesem wahlabend wenn wir
ehrlich sind auch nicht gleich die
richtigen schlüsse gezogen ich erinnere
mich noch gut wie der abend so lief und
ich kann als jemand der schon mal am
wahlabend dass durchlebt hat einfach nur
empfehlen vielleicht jetzt bisher waren
sie nicht die bonita kunden da waren wir
wir waren an den ball haben haben wir
bei denen weiter ergebnis nicht demütig
genug ganz ehrlich das ist vielleicht
eine lehre jetzt auch für die man ist
gefragt hat ob nicht ganz kurz
hoffnungsträger ist der hendrik wüst
jetzt der neue strahlende cdu
hoffnungsträger
für mich immer schwer wenn wenn wenn
ministerpräsidenten im amt die viele
jahre auch als minister man immer noch
als hoffnungsträger es ministerpräsident
monates ministerpräsident des größten
bundeslandes eines vierte tor angeraten
wird es wahrscheinlich auch bleiben und
bleiben können und er gehört natürlich
zum team cdu ganz vorne mit dabei und
das ist ja das was union ausmacht von
michael kretschmer daniel günther
hendrik wüst reiner haseloff volker
bouffier markus söder das sind alles
ministerpräsidenten mit einem klaren
profil charakterköpfe an denen sich
mancher auch manchmal fallen sie beide
und konkurrenz da haben in
nordrhein-westfalen und will mir ein
könnte ja es sollte sagen wie toll der
hendrik wüst bericht die für ihren
mitfreuen und sagen das ist der neue
mann im bund machen sie nicht spricht
auch also herr war einmal ist marcel
weise was zählt ist gesagt ins gespräch
also holt das ist aber so ein typischer
weise so geht das können sie jetzt auch
nicht so stehen lassen ich habe
geantwortet und sie antworten hat nur
gesagt ich habe gesagt ich tue mich
schwer da ich werde ja auch noch
manchmal ich finde über 40 jährige immer
als hoffnungsträger das sagt man nicht
viel zu 20 jährigen das ist ein
gestandener ministerpräsident er
natürlich zum führungsteam der cdu
gehört das habe ich gesagt und glauben
sie mir einst als münsterländer freut
sich niemand mehr als ich nämlich auch
münsterländer dass hendrik wüst
ministerpräsident bleibt also versuchen
sie jetzt nicht der ihm eigenen art
manchmal da weiß rhein zurück ich habe
das interpretiert was sie gesagt haben
der zuschauer macht sich sein eigenes
bild davon er lud wir haben gerade
darüber gesprochen was der moralische
ist an koalition und nicht also ist es
unmoralisch wenn man jetzt als spd sagt
wir versuchen das durchaus mit den
grünen die super stark geworden sind
heute und mit einer fdp noch so eine
ampel koalition zu schmieden würden sie
das als wähler unmoralisch wenn ich also
ich glaube zunächst mal das ist
unmoralisch ist von moral zu sprechen in
solchen fragen wir haben artikel 38
grundgesetz der die unabhängigkeit der
abgeordneten konstituiert und sowie die
sich denn dann eben entscheiden und
nicht aufgrund irgendwelcher
kaffeesatzleserei die versuchten
ergebnis zu erklären wird es eine
koalition der einen oder der anderen
geben und ich bin davon überzeugt wenn
die fdp doch noch mit ach und krach
reinkommt dann wird sie alles machen um
steigbügelhalter für rot grün zu werden
in nordrhein westfalen und dann wird
erneut wüst der von einem drittel der
wenigen die gewählt haben es werden ja
leider immer weniger wir haben jetzt
hier die zahlen noch nicht aber
insgesamt geht die wahlbeteiligung seit
jahren zurück werden wir erleben dass
hendrik wüst nicht mehr
ministerpräsident sein wird in diesem
fall aber sei gewesen das halte ich für
völlig ausgeschlossen also und zwar aus
einem grund der offensichtlich ist für
die grünen ist es von interesse jetzt
eine schwarz-grüne koalition einzugehen
also man muss ja mal hart sagen das war
eigentlich die idee die die grünen immer
hatten auch für die bundestagswahl 2021
man wollte schwarz grün das ist
gescheitert weil die cdu den falschen
kandidaten aufgestellt hat mit herrn
laschet das muss man mal so hart sagen
also hätte man so wahrgenommen das ist
meine prognose hätte es gereicht für
schwarz grün und dann hätten die grünen
auch schwarz grün gemacht so jetzt ist
die ampel da die grünen sind in dieser
ampel auch sehr glücklich die ampel aus
meiner sicht da bin ich anderer meinung
als herr jörges funktioniert auch aber
es würde mich aber für die grünen kann
es jetzt nicht die option sein sich auf
dauer immer auf eine ampel fest zu
liegen komme was da wolle sondern man
hat ja auch in schleswig-holstein schon
erfolgreich hinter sich gebracht wie es
da weitergeht wird man ja sehen so aber
jetzt ist eigentlich in nordrhein
westfalen da muss ich ja ausnahmsweise
mal kein sparen recht geben
schwarz grün
schwarz grün sozusagen etwas was
eigentlich sozusagen normal wäre jetzt
kann es natürlich sein dass herr wüst
fehler macht in den
koalitionsverhandlungen und unzumutbare
würden darauf richtet so dass die grünen
sagen hey mit dem kann man gar nicht
koalieren der will hier überhaupt nichts
für die energiewende machen nicht also
wenn von wüst jetzt kommt beim thema
windrad dann wird er auch keine
koalition mit den grünen sehen aber das
glaube ich nicht dass er dafür das nicht
gewählt ja ist ja nicht gewählt wurde
eine koalition mit grünen und
der cdu landes das ist doch das was die
wähler so frustriert aber das ist immer
wieder solche argumente haben ja der ist
angewachsen die erstmal wissen sie denn
je genauer an und die extreme rechte
hand an gewachsen wären würde doch
niemand sagen
ich habe mir das immer vielen
bürgerinnen und bürgern gesprochen in
münzen wochen in nordrhein-westfalen ich
in berlin mitte und ich habe einen
ziemlich klaren eindruck dass das
wahlergebnis schon auch dass ihre frage
ist
zufällig komme ich ja und das ist
eigentlich nicht der frage dann will
niemand eine koalition der cdu mit den
grünen das ist doch absurd sie haben
gesagt ja sein aber die gespräche der
letzten wochen zeigen doch ein ist also
ich hab ja nur den letzten vier fünf
sechs wochen erlebt wie das auch
stimmungsmäßig sich entwickelt hat vor
vier fünf wochen es waren keine leichten
wochen auch nicht bei der stimmung in
der cdu für die wahlkämpfer aber es gab
jetzt noch mal einen richtigen endspurt
und eine eines gab es auf jeden fall
eine stimmung dass hendrik wüst
ministerpräsident bleiben soll eben
nordrhein westfalen und das ist zeigt
man zeigt sich eben auch in diesem
wahlergebnis und da sie ja gerade die
frage des grundgesetzes und anderer
dinge angesprochen haben jetzt geht es
eben natürlich darum auch eine mehrheit
im landtag zu bilden die das auch
abbildet und abbilden kann so und
deswegen kann ich ehrlich gesagt mit
diesem herleiten wie sie es gerade
gemacht haben eine ampel bei der jetzt
zwei parteien die in der ampel wären
deutlich verloren hätten also daraus ein
wähler hat will er auf einmal zu lassen
und darauf an wie wir sind ja doch
zusammengesetzt nicht wie es sich mal
irgendwann
es kommt doch am ende drauf an was diese
super stolzen grünen entscheiden heute
der gigantische schweine wer regiert und
die entscheiden auch über wie viele
minister ämter sie kriegen der regierung
wenn sie eine drei parteien regierung
drängt sie entsprechend weniger
ministerämter zwei parteien regierung
die bedeutung in einer schwarz grünen
regierung ist viel größer es gibt ja
auch das ist ja noch ein experiment da
gebe ich ihnen völlig recht dass wollen
die schon lange mal ausprobieren und der
wirst ist ja eher einer aus dem
konservativen bereich der partei der
muss ich da ein bisschen in die
steilkurve legen um den was zu bieten
dass wir da ganz sicher tun ist der
forschung angekündigt und nochmal zur
frage hoffnungsträgern brown ist ja so
stark geworden herr kutschaty hat ihn
stark gemacht mit seiner ankündigung vor
der wahl wird auch versuchen aus der
zweiten position einer regierung zu
bilden das war quasi der aufruf an viele
fdp-wähler die keine rot grüne koalition
wollen die cdu zu wählen das haben sie
auch gemacht und was nun den
hoffnungsträgern da sehe ich überhaupt
nicht das ist noch weit hin bis zur
nächsten bundestagswahl
und ich sage mal aus nordrhein westfalen
ist noch nie ein kanzler gekommen es
haben schon drei versucht und sind es
nicht geworden nämlich johannes rau und
herr steinbrück und herr laschet und
auch herr wüst ist meine prognose heute
abend wird nicht kanzler werden dazu
fehlt ihm jede form aber dass du nicht
alles herzlich einst sogar seinen sohn
war haben schon wieder geschäft ich
freue mich erst mal über den ergebnissen
weil man muss erst einmal weiter denken
also das interessante ist tatsächlich
vor allem weil ihr herr spahn jetzt da
ist würde mich das auch interessieren
wie ihr das sieht das eigentlich durch
diese beiden wahlergebnisse in
schleswig-holstein und in nordrhein
westfalen hat man jetzt eigentlich zwei
starken männer in der cdu die beides
wahlsieger sind das ist ja wichtig auch
wenn es um die bundestagswahl geht
werden normalerweise nicht immer aber
normalerweise kandidaten genommen die
schon eine wahl richtig deutlich
gewonnen haben und interessanterweise
ist dass beide wahlsieger jetzt auch für
sehr unterschiedliche konzepte stehen
also herr wüst hat ja herr jörges gerade
gesagt ist eigentlich eher die
konservative cdu ist eigentlich eher die
märz linie günther hat mit einer
modernen cdu gewonnen hat das auch immer
nach vorne gestellt die so und jetzt hat
eigentlich die cdu die wahl zwischen
zwei konzepten und zwei sehr starken
ministerpräsidenten
natürlich seien das hat auch noch die
wahl zwischen verschiedenen leuten in
berlin in der bundesbank nennt werden
natürlich unter sich aus oder kanzler
kann das sonst einmal lasst uns einmal
die runde noch ein bisschen erweitern es
gerade schon zitiert worden von ihnen
herr sparen norbert walter borjans ist
uns zugeschaltet da aus düsseldorf aus
dem landtag wir haben noch mal gerade
frische zahlen reingekommen sind schönen
guten abend herr walter boltz die
nämlich nochmal die spd etwas schwächer
sehen als nach der ersten prognose und
die cdu noch mal ein bisschen stärker
sehen und trotzdem sagt die spd
wir geben uns da noch nicht geschlagen
wir könnten uns noch vorstellen zu
regieren nämlich wenn man eine ampel
hinbekommen die rechnerisch ja auch
denkbar wäre jetzt sagt hier die runde
weitestgehend das wäre unmoralisch wenn
die spd da als wahlverlierer jetzt um
die ecke kommt und am ende noch regiert
sagt auch ihren sparen das hat der unter
brawns ich habe herrn weiter treu und
zitiert genau eigenes it also ihr
eigenes zitat geht es heute doch ist das
unmoralisch wenn sie da jetzt regieren
in nordrhein westfalen weiter bei 1
also ich habe mich schon gewundert werde
mich jetzt wie zitiert also ich sage
erst mal ein schulten abend in die runde
ich sage auch an jetzt sparen ganz klar
herzlichen glückwunsch zu diesem
wahlergebnis ich sage das auch an die
adresse der grünen
ich habe heute schon an anderer stelle
auch gesagt dass wir alles andere als
zufrieden sind als spd mit diesem
ergebnis überhaupt keine frage aber
es ist doch auch kein geheimnis dass die
selbsternannte nrw koalition aus cdu und
fdp ihre mehrheit verloren also ist
abgewählt worden die verschiebung von
fdp cdu hat offenbar nicht ausgereicht
um in der summe konstant zu bleiben
und es ist nun einmal so das hat ja auch
das habe ich eben mit bekommen ist schon
diskutiert worden
armin laschet versucht dass man
natürlich weiß am ende stellt den
regierungschef der im regelfall stärkste
partner einer mehrheitskoalition
und da wird es noch ein langer abend man
muss sich das angucken man muss sich
auch mal angucken was haben denn vorher
auch in umfragen wählerinnen und wähler
als präferenzen dargestellt es ist jetzt
nicht der augenblick
praktisch da ansprüche anzumelden
die grünen haben enorm gewonnen und die
grünen werden sicher begehrte
gesprächspartner sein und sie werden mit
sicherheit auch
punkte darstellen die sie in einer
regierung realisiert haben wollen ich
glaube das ist gerade bei dem was ja
offenbar die nrw koalition schwarz gelb
abgelöst hat eine menge von pumpen
gehabt die die anderen vater die
derzeitige opposition sind
mit besseren erwartungen aus stadt und
jetzt müssen wir einfach mal gucken wie
wird das weitergehen die spd ist jetzt
sicher nicht diejenige die den anspruch
erhebt aber die doch sagen kann das
rot-grüne mehrheit projekt oder das
mehrheitsbündnis wäre möglicherweise
möglich und darüber wird sicher auch von
den grünen mit geredet und das ergebnis
gucken uns dann an
ersparen das klingt nicht so als würde
sicher weiter bei uns anders von ihnen
genannte zitat und das walter borjans
zitat in diesem fall noch gerne erinnern
tja ich wunder mich etwas ich sei normal
das war ja nicht mein zitat jawohl herr
walter borjans
herr jörges kurz einfach er hat
jetzt hat nach der bundestagswahl gesagt
man kann als zweiter versuchen eine
mehrheit zu bauen aber moralisch ist das
nicht lars klingbeil hat im übrigen
gesagt wer ein historisch das historisch
schlechteste ergebnis in seiner
geschichte eingefahren hat der sollte
nicht regieren wollen das waren alles
zitate aus september und ich verstehe
nicht ganz wie die partei und sogar
dieselben leute ist ist ja nicht mal nur
dieselbe partei ist so dieselben
vertreter der partei uns jetzt das
genaue gegenteil erzählen das ist das
historisch schlechteste ergebnis
hannelore kraft hat 2017 nach dem
historisch schlechtesten ergebnis für
damals noch unterboten worden jetzt für
die spd nrw gesagt sie übernimmt
verantwortung und tritt zurück und jetzt
will jemand der noch schlechter als frau
kraft gewesen ist nicht nur nicht
zurücktreten sondern leitet daraus ein
regierungs- und führungsanspruch ab das
finde ich auch mit dem ergebnis wie es
heute ist ehrlich gesagt ziemlich gewagt
und das kann man auch so nicht einfach
stehenlassen und im übrigen weiß ich
noch ziemlich gut dass die nordrhein
westfalen auch rot-grün erinnern ich
meine wir waren schlusslicht in allen
fragen beim wirtschaftswachstum hatten
die höchste arbeitslosigkeit bei der
inneren sicherheit gab es zwar viel
raser marathon aber wenig bekämpfung der
tatsächlichen kriminalität ich habe
nicht den eindruck dass die bürgerinnen
und bürger zu rot grün zurück wollen
ganz sicher nicht
das mag ja jetzt ihr eindruck sein
ersparen aber aber aber herr walter
borjans einer herr walter borjans warum
sind sie jetzt nicht so ehrlich und
sagen ja da geben wir uns halt der
niederlage hin das ist heute das
wahlergebnis auch wenn man es nicht
mögen und das rechne wird irgendwie noch
reichen würde wir sind halt irgendwie in
wahlverlierer heute neben der fdp auch
das wäre jetzt nicht das richtige dinge
das würde der stimmung dort in
nordrhein-westfalen nehmen nicht
entsprechen wenn wir jetzt regieren
warum sagen sie ist nicht einfach weil
es nicht stimmt
na ja weil ich ja auch nach anderen
dingen schon gefragt worden bin doch
gerade in dieser runde oder mich auch
dazu verhalten will dass herr spahn sagt
also er hat gerade eine bilanz
aufgemacht ich kann nun wirklich aus
meinem eigenen ressort sagen dass ich an
vielen stellen im land angesprochen
werde dass diese regierung in den
letzten fünf jahren bei allem was das
thema steuergerechtigkeit angeht
abgebaut hat ja klar versagt hat und
auch das ist teil der wahrheit wir
wissen jetzt dass die bildungspolitik
dieser koalition die schlechtesten noten
bekommen hat als was ich erst mal sagen
will ist es hat ja offenbar eine
verschiebung gegeben von fdp cdu mit dem
ergebnis dass die beiden partner
schwächer geworden sind das stellt und
es hat auch eine verschiebung gegeben
von f spd zu grünen mit dem ergebnis
dieses beiden partner während stärker
das halte ich erstmal für einmal ganz
und das ist auch ein unterschied ob sie
das unterschreibt dieser sache möchte
schon es ist auch ein unterschied ob
herr laschet bei dem ganz klar fest
gemacht worden ist dieser kandidat hat
die wahl verloren noch den anspruch
erhebt dann kanzler zu werden und
insofern sage ich jetzt erst mal ich bin
weit entfernt davon
dieses ergebnis dass wir jetzt erzielt
haben hochzujubeln ich sage der abend
wird noch lang wir gucken uns an wie
könnten stabile mehrheit optionen in
diesem land aussehen was könnte ansatz
für eine fortschrittliche politik der
zukunftspolitik in diesem land sein und
dann arbeitet mit der verlierer moral
gilt nur wenn sie nicht selber der
verlierer sind
nein ich habe gerade gesagt dass ich ein
paar dinge entscheidend unterscheiden
zwischen diesen beiden wahlergebnissen
auf bundesebene und jetzt aber ich
bleibe auch dabei ich stehe hier nicht
mit aufgeblasenen backen und sage dass
es von vornherein klares ergebnis wie es
zu laufen hat sondern es werden
gespräche geführt werden mit sicherheit
natürlich mit dem
ministerpräsidenten dieses landes und
sehr erstarkten grünen aber es wird mit
sicherheit auch gespräche zwischen
anderen partnern geben das gehört zur
demokratie dazu und die spd weiß was für
ein ergebnis eingefahren hat sie weiß
aber auch welche optionen und welche
ziele förstern umsetzbar sind mit ihrer
beteiligung und das werden wir jetzt
eben sehen wenn man mehr wissen über das
ergebnis und mehr über die gespräche
wieder einzuführen sei weiter als hans
ulrich jörges hat gerade noch
interessant gesagt da steckt auch eine
menge olaf scholz drin und er hat gesagt
ihr müsst ihr jetzt ganz schnell
reagieren der müsste ganz schnell sein
kabinett umbauen und zwar so dass er
gleich zwei rausschmeißt lauterbach aus
sagt lamprecht passiert das
sie wissen dass ich nicht mehr
vorsitzender der spd finde und insofern
das ganze und ausland suchen distanz
sehen kann natürlich den engen kontakt
mit den beteiligten aber die na'vi aber
ich gehöre nicht zu diesen ehemaligen
vorsitzenden egal welcher partei die
danach über fernsehen sie haben immer
eine meinung die er fand aber konstant
wissen lassen wie es zu laufen hat die
ich habe immer eine meinung ja aber die
muss ich nicht unbedingt in wirklichkeit
zum besten geben sondern doch dafür gibt
es auch schon mal ein telefon
eine letzte frage dann würden sie denn
selber wieder aktiv werden wenn sie sich
da gerade schon so raus nehmen also wenn
kurz starte jetzt dass doch noch macht
obwohl er heute ja nicht zu den
gewinnern zählt wenn er dann eine ampel
schmiede dann werden sie wieder
finanzminister in nordrhein westfalen
na ja das machen ja im mit folie
rockgruppen schon mal dass sie nach
abschluss tourneen immer wieder ein
comeback machen aber ich habe schon eine
klare aussage gemacht dass das für mich
ein
rundes ding weil diese zwei jahre noch
einmal für meine partei drangehängt zu
haben und ich habe jetzt eine
entscheidung getroffen
es an andere zu übergeben und so soll
das auch bleiben danke herzlich für das
gespräch hierbei bild live norbert
walter borjans der ex-spd-chef heute
über diese ja so sieht's aus dem
momentanen niederlage in seinem
bundesland in nordrhein-westfalen danke
herzlich wird diskutiert die hunde bahn
anschließend cellos schließen sie aus
dass sie in die landespolitik nrw zurück
ja noch dort ministeramt übernehmen oder
bleiben sie in berlin und ihre karriere
hat er sich einen gedankengang ich darf
noch mal der mal fragen ja solche
gedankengänge haben politiker
normalerweise deshalb haben wir sind
hoch nachdem der lange politik
beobachtet haben also sie bleiben in
berlin oder denken sie auch an der
möglichkeit in düssel brauch ich fühle
mich in berlin sehr wohl gut danke dann
lasst es uns diskutieren über das was
dieses wahlergebnis heute aus sagt für
uns alle in deutschland auch für berlin
dass es einmal über die grünen
diskutieren das ist ja wirklich der
erstaunliche geschichte die grünen die
in diesen sechs monaten gigantisch
gewachsen sind die beliebtesten minister
und ministerinnen stehen erstellen im
moment ganz vorne an der werburg dann
robert habeck dann cem özdemir auch noch
hier irgendwie den kompletten film davon
der ampel einsammeln für sich warum
ulrike herrmann sind die im moment so
stark warum finden die deutschen
irgendwie dass die grünen nicht alles
richtig machen die stoßen sich auch viel
an denen und trotzdem finden sie die
richtig gut die schneiden den umfragen
gut abschneiden bei den wahlen gut ab
naja also erstmal muss man glaube ich
ganz grundsätzlich sagen dass die grüne
partei die partei ist mit den meisten
politischen begabungen also das ist ja
in gewisser weise auch das drama der spd
gewesen dass diese neugründung die
grünen praktisch über jahrzehnte fast
die gesamten talente abgegraben hat die
sind immer alle zu den grünen gegangen
also die grünen sind die einzige partei
die egal um welches amt das geht das
geht bis runter in den stadtrat immer
mehr talente haben als plätze nicht in
allen anderen parteien muss man das
jetzt mal so deutlich sagen ist es
andersrum ja das gilt auch für die cdu
aus meiner sicht sollten sie können aber
das andere ist natürlich dass die grünen
ich glaube das hat auch alle hat es hier
schon gesagt vielleicht ersparen oder
herr jörges die grünen haben eigentlich
jetzt das war ein historischer zufall
jetzt die ministerposten besetzt die
also in der ukraine krise sagt wir haben
ein kleinen kanzlei das ist natürlich
auch die haben auch die richtigen
positionen um jetzt in der ukraine sehr
wichtig zu sein also außenpolitik
wirtschaftspolitik gedeckt wir haben
jetzt ja auch total unpopuläre
entscheidungen treffen
und geschichte mit dem gas ihr und haben
sie recht also sind alle sehr unpopuläre
entscheidungen hammer entscheidungen
also aber sie haben tatsächlich und das
hat herr jörges auch schon sagt stimmt
politiker die das tatsächlich erklären
können also uns war der
kommunikationsstil der wird schule
machen ich bin sicher demnächst macht
die cdu das auch so also der der
kommunikationsstil ist ja so dass man
die wähler bei der entscheidungsfindung
mit nimmt also nicht sagt er ist eine
gute idee ich hab das ja alle nein ich
hab das doch harbeck also das ist doch
nicht ich hab das ja alles im griff ich
weiß sowieso alles besser sondern ich
erkläre euch wo das problem ist und dann
erkläre ich euch warum ich das jetzt so
hin dass schon zu hause vor der kamera
mit dem mit dem handy diesen haarweg
diesen haarberg style diese videos
aufzunehmen so locker das zu erklären
wird es schon trainiert in cdu rat also
erst einmal setzt das natürlich ein
gewisser weise entstanden da muss man ja
auch einfach sagen chapeau dass das ist
schon gut vor allem in dieser abwägung
gleichwohl glaube ich dass wir das in
anderer art und weise in den letzten
jahren ist nicht halt immer dran es gibt
unterschiedliche arten zu kommunizieren
auch gesehen haben aber der annalena
baerbock und robert habeck machen da
gerade einfach einen guten job in der
schwierigen zeigen das muss man auch
anerkennen
gleichzeitig auch bei dieser
kommunikation auch bei insta und in
interviews viel ankündigen ist natürlich
das ist dann unsere aufgabe auch als
opposition in 1 23 jahren ist dann halt
auch mal zeit wo hingeschaut wird also
es wird gerade ziemlich viel zu gesagt
und versprochen von der frage dass wir
durch den nächsten winter kommen auch
ohne russischen gas was ich noch nicht
ganz glauben und ich möchte gerne mal
die zahlen die berechnungen dazu sehen
bis hin zu der frage dass wir in den
nächsten drei vier jahren so viel
erneuerbare ausbauen wie nie zuvor das
sind alles dinge da kann man jetzt viel
erklären bei instagram jetzt wollen wir
dann aber in zwei drei jahren auch sehen
ob es passiert ist
und das glaube ich wird man dann auch
noch mal messen und bemessen müssen eins
ist übrigens noch wichtig für die
sozialdemokratie ich hab das ja
jahrelang in der großen koalition erlebt
die haben ja immer so vor sich hin
gedämmert in der großen koalition als
juniorpartner wer alles furchtbar und
sie hätten gar nichts davon und sie
würden so viel erfolge haben und keiner
merkt jetzt sind sie die stärkste partei
in der koalition stellen den kanzler und
an und es ist immer noch so dass sie
verlieren nicht stärker werden und am
ende als jammertal main am ende am ende
ist ja sogar mit stolz ich meine ganz
nrw war zu plakatiert mit olaf scholz
jetzt die letzten zwei tage was heißt
das jetzt
dass die ersten hin dieses jammern die
spd hatten viel tiefer liegendes problem
als sie an die sozialdemokratische
jahrzehnt wurde ausgerufen nach der
bundestagswahl bei eigentlich einem
relativ schlechten ergebnis wir hatten
ein noch schlechteres aber es war kein
berauschendes ergebnis und ich glaube
die spd muss tatsächlich mal anfangen
wirklich zu schauen ob all das was sie
sich so erzählt und erzählt hat ob das
nicht viel zu oberflächlich war und sie
nicht eigentlich viel tiefer liegendes
problem hat ob es eine partei wie die
spd in der welt und problemlage die wir
haben überhaupt noch so braucht so
übersieht das noch besser herleiten ja
es ist doch so
also selbst im ruhrgebiet dass die spd
doch weit weit weg jetzt bei dieser
landtagswahl von dem was sie da mal war
und das ist ihr stammland der
unterschied ob sie in kanzler stellt
oder nicht also das was wir über jahre
immer gehört haben dass das das
eigentliche probleme das jedenfalls ist
offenkundig nicht dass die spd überhaupt
noch die frage wird jens spahn ja das
kommt darauf an welche spd es ist und
das gilt ja im übrigen meines erachtens
aber noch viel stärker für die fdp nur
weil eine partei irgendwie heißt wird
sie nicht gebraucht sie wird dann
gebraucht wenn sie einen klaren inhalt
vertritt und einen klaren kurs hat und
ich eben halt auch tatsächlich am tag
vor der wahl sehen können was ich am tag
nach der wahl bekommen und das ist genau
das was wir glaube ich hier auch sehen
das ganz ganz deutlich die parteien
abgestraft werden die einfach gar keinen
klar erkennbaren kern und inhalten haben
und 1 henrik wüst richtig gemacht gerade
auch wenn ich im übrigen aus münsterland
schaue der ganz klassische cdu wähler im
münsterland der fühlt sich von dem
storytelling ist angenehmer mensch hat
keinem was getan bis jetzt noch kein
großer bekannter skandal der fühlt sich
da erst mal mitgenommen bei thomas
kutschaty ist das wird etwas ganz
anderes der versucht letztlich den
arbeiterführer dazugeben ist es aber
eben halt auch biografische und das
merken die leute und bei der fdp war es
eben halt das schlimmste wenn wir uns
erinnern an joachim stamm der der impf
doch einfach mit lustig gesungen hat und
damit im prinzip alles verraten hat
wofür die fdp da inhaltlich stand dann
ist das ganz klar das merken die leute
unter wenden sie sich ab und die grünen
auch wenn ich die inhalte nicht teile
machen wenigstens ein ist die vertreten
ihre position konsequent also mehrere
parteien sogar müssen sich fragen
braucht sie überhaupt nur hermann jens
spahn wirft diese frage heute noch mal
frisch auf und sagt die spd muss sich
doch offenbar fragen ob da ein tiefer
liegendes problem da ist möglicherweise
ob es sie überhaupt noch braucht ja also
ich glaube dass die spd gebraucht wird
deswegen habe ich auch so genug warum
weil sie eigentlich die partei ist die
sozusagen das soziale gewissen jetzt
repräsentiert also das hat sie
zwischendurch mit hartz4 und so auch mal
verraten aber im augenblick gibt es
jetzt keine andere partei die
beispielsweise mit dieser
glaubwürdigkeit solche themen durchsetzt
wie der mindestlohn man hat ja nach der
wahl als nach dem bundes wegen der
inflation völlig wurscht und werden so
ehrlich gesagt nicht findest du uns
immer wichtig selbst bei einer inflation
jetzt kann man ihn weiter fortsetzen
die inflation konnten die route egal
genau die information kommt richtig die
löhne sondern durch die energiepreise
auf den weltmeeren rüber sagt auch schon
gemerkt wollte damit nur fern bei der
viktoria politisch namen verrate ich
jetzt noch mal kurz das gebäude das ist
ja beides richtigen diesmal jedenfalls
hat man nach der bundestagswahl
analysiert was die erfolgreichsten nach
narrativen also slogans und dabei kam
eindeutig raus das war sozusagen der
absolute höhepunkt zwei dinge waren
wirklich wichtig nämlich erstens der
mindestlohn von zehn euro und zweitens
dieser satz front scholz es geht um
respekt so und damit war die spd
erfolgreich und im augenblick ist immer
noch die einzige partei jedenfalls auf
bundesebene die das besetzt und deswegen
würde ich jetzt anstatt also anstelle
der cdu nicht schließen wir waren total
erfolgreich in nrw jetzt hat sich das
aber mit der spd auf bundesebene total
erledigt nicht dass
das war ein super stichwort weil da ist
doch die frage ob die spd das im moment
erfüllt sie haben den fall lamprecht
schon reinigen
sendung also dieses wort respekt das
stand ja wirklich auf jedem wahlplakat
darauf hin dass man verbindet der wähler
mit diesem wort respekt sowie unter
hermann das gerade sagt tatsächlich noch
die spd laut der wähler hat der spd
wähler hat das in der zeit von herrn
schulz sehr viel wörtlich genommen als
es jetzt nimmt das ist ein relikt aus
der schulter hat auch ständig von
respekt das war eine einzige vokabel
hatte war unglaublich erfolgreich ich
frage ich glaube nicht dass sich die
frage gestellt welche parteien man noch
braucht wenn eine partei entsprechend
starkes und parlamenten sitz hat sie ein
recht dazu seien punkt und da stellt
sich die frage ob man sie braucht gar
nicht stellt sich bei der
regierungsbildung aber heute abend hat
sich dann noch ein sehr interessantes
oder zwei andere interessante ergebnisse
geben die linke ist offensichtlich in
westdeutschland erledigt das stimmt
historisch erledigten dann stellt sich
die frage ist ja schon bei der
bundestagswahl prozentual gesehen unter
fünf prozent geblieben und nur eine
bundestag gekommen weil sie zwei mandate
geholt hat ist sie überhaupt historisch
erledigt auch im osten das muss man noch
ein bisschen abwarten und die afg hat
sich heute abend die leute die sich da
versammelt hatten hair group aller der
parteivorsitzende erleichtert umarmt
dass sie über fünf prozent gelandet
waren ich meine die haben wir haben uns
ein bild erinnerte hatten sie 25 oder 30
auch die afg zeit geht zu ende und ja es
ist gottlob offensichtlich
offensichtlich dass müssen vorsichtig
sein jetzt ein ergebnis des ukraine
kriegsjahr weil lisa die sind halt noch
reingekommen heute abend man könnte es
auch so rum wenden die sind stärker als
die fdp plötzlich in nordrhein westfalen
heißt es ja viel klarer das sagen sie
ganz toll die hat sich erledigt und
ulrike herrmann sein so kfd ist ja die
erleichternde geschichte die linke ist
ja gar kein problem mehr die linke ist
ja wie die spd das hat also interessant
warum ist die linke erledigt warum
spielt man jetzt ist genau das was
passiert ist also die spd ist mit ihrem
slogan respekt und mindestlohn 12 euro
ist sie ja faktisch wieder nach links
gerückt also die in winden sich erinnert
wenn die linkspartei gegründet wurde das
war 2005 oder da sind sie zum ersten mal
in der bundestagswahl angetreten
es ist der rechtsnachfolge
und da ist schon wieder was es ist nun
mal ein faktum das schon okay aber dass
sie der linkspartei diesen schub
bekommen hat und auch im westen stark
würde und nicht nur eine pds im osten
war das hat der mit hat viel zu tun
gehabt da wird dadurch wurde ist eine
rechtspartei und auch so stark dass man
da immer schön im bundestag ordentlich
stimmen von der spd klären konnte und
jetzt hat ja die spd praktisch der
hartz4 wieder eingerollt ist
zurückgegangen hat das dann erst haben
sie es schweigsam gemacht in der großen
koalition wurden ja schon viele fehler
von hartz4
teure korrigiert aber das hat man immer
nicht gemerkt und jetzt hat es dann auch
scholz sozusagen verbalisiert mit seinen
respekt und seine sein mindestlohn und
damit hat natürlich die linkspartei
eigentlich ihren daseinsberechtigung
auch so ein bisschen verloren weil die
spd jetzt wieder zurück gewandert ist
und gleichzeitig das muss man ja hier
jetzt nicht vertiefen gibt es diese
ganzen probleme dass sie putin verstehe
sind dass sie sich nicht einigen konnten
wie sie corona maßnahmen finden dass es
schwierigkeiten gab ganz generell mit
der friedenspolitik außenpolitik und so
weiter ist ein permanentes tohuwabohu in
nrw tauchte dann natürlich auch noch die
causa wagenknecht aus so und das sich an
protein an geschmeckt hat für den wird's
halt im moment ziemlich eng stehen
offenbar auf der falschen seite der
geschichte diesmal von der anderen haben
sie übrigens die neueste hochrechnung
gesehen haben wir gesehen dass bald ein
unterschied zwischen cdu und spd von
neun prozent also ich weiß nicht was
noch passieren muss wir werden zwar im
laufe des abends sehen ist die spd
anerkennt dass sie nicht regieren sollte
wenn wir nachher nochmal nach wir haben
noch weitere spd gäste auch in dieser
sendung auch karl lauterbach übrigens
der noch bei uns war sein wird später
sie müssen nicht weg ersparen deswegen
ganz kurz an sie noch einmal die frage
wie hansjörg ist aufgeworfen hat raus
mit den ministern also raus mit
lamprecht lauers mit lauterbach würden
sie das zu tun
das muss der bundeskanzler entscheiden
ich will mich da wissen sie ich finde
das immer schwierig kommen gerade vor
sechs sieben acht monaten aus einer
regierung die abgewählt worden ist
jedenfalls der unions teil deswegen will
ich da jetzt nicht in diese persönlichen
bewertungen hineingehen aber herr jörges
hat doch einiges dazu gesagt ich frage
auch deswegen weil das natürlich schon
ging es angehörige familienmitglieder
mit fliegen zu lassen in der luftwaffe
der bundeswehr im luftwaffen heli was
ist ihre meinung dazu wissen ich habe es
ja selbst auch erlebt in der pandemie
und übrigens auch zurecht erlebt und
durchlebt das natürlich ist auch meine
frage ist in welchen zeiten sind wir
gerade was ist die situation auch der
bürgerinnen und bürger die pandemie war
eine harte zeit und da musste ich mich
auch manche debatte stellen und damit
natürlich ganz genau geschaut wie
verhalten sich auch regierungsmitglieder
und das gilt natürlich in dieser
kriegszeit in europa noch viel viel mehr
und in der frage der bundeswehr der
bundeswehr ausstattung und da verstehe
ich schon dass viele bürgerinnen und
bürger sich sehr stören an diesen
bildern aber vor allem auch wie ich
finde an dem umgang anschließend damit
das ist der eine minister fall der
andere den hans ulrich jörges
aufgeworfen hat es lauterbach lauterbach
sagt heute direkt vor der wahl waren
zitat aus der rheinischen post die cdu
ist wegen der impfpflicht die sie mit
verhindert hat diese auch die auch sie
nie wirklich wollten schuld wenn es
künftig mehr corona todesfall
aufgetreten mit ja genau ich was soll
man also für teilweise dazu fehlen mir
jetzt viel ein zu sagen aber ich habe
mir eins vorgenommen und das wissen sie
ich werde die kohlepolitik die aktuelle
nicht kommentieren ich finde das macht
jetzt gar nicht um seine ich fragte es
wirklich um seine politik da geht es um
krassen vor der naja es widerspricht er
den eigentlich was selbst mal gesagt
worden ist in der bundestagsdebatte dass
man eben nicht in vorwürfe verfallen
will anscheinend ist die not groß aber
ich sage noch einmal ich werde ansonsten
aktuell nicht mal bei dtv aktuelle
corona und tag danach wenn ich das weiß
und das ist keine bewertung des
ministers sondern das ist eine antwort
auf ein krasses zitat des von ihnen
kommt von karl lauterbach und das krass
trifft schon ziemlich cool wir machen
eine ganz kurze pause danke ihnen
ersparen wir diskutieren hier gleich
weiter mit ihnen herr lothar mit frau
herrmann mit von jörges und später dann
auch mit karl lauterbach in dieser
sendung kurz durchschnaufen dann zurück
mit den richtigen fragen hierbei wird
[Musik]
zurück bei wählt die richtigen fragen an
einem wahlabend was für ein wahlsonntag
hier das größte das ja wenn man so will
wichtigste bundesland hat heute
abgestimmt hat heute gewählt nordrhein
westfalen mit folgen auch für sie alle
zu hause selbst wenn sie nicht dort
leben und das liegt an diesen zahlen
hier die cdu nämlich feiert einen
wahlsieg in nordrhein westfalen mit 35,9
prozent der stimmen dass die aktuellste
hochrechnung dort aus dem bundesland die
spd kommt nur noch auf 27 das hatte die
sich anders vorgestellt auch weil das
bundesland nordrhein-westfalen bei der
bundestagswahl komplett rot angemalt war
und in diesen sechs monaten jetzt hat
man drastisch verloren dort bei der spd
ist jetzt eben ganz klar nur
zweitstärkste kraft und dann schauen sie
auf die grünen das ist eine ganz
gewichtige geschichte dieses
wahlsonntags heute die sind von 6
prozent gekommen und kann jetzt seit 18
prozent also ganz schnell überschlagen
das sind mehr als dreimal so viele
stimmen wie bisher die sind richtig
mächtig jetzt in nordrhein westfalen die
könnten schwarz grün machen die könnten
aber auch noch so wie es aussieht der
cdu und schnippchen schlagen dann
regiert daneben mich nicht hendrik wüst
sondern einer ampel gehen das würde
rechnerisch reichen die könnten mit der
spd zusammen gehen und mit einer mini
geschrumpften fdp die ganz knapp noch
über die fünf prozent hürde kommen nach
der aktuellsten hochrechnung auf 5,3
auch das würde reichen die wahlsieger
cdu und grüne könnten schwarz-grün
bilden aber es könnte auch eine
koalition der wahlverlierer mit den
grünen werden dort in nordrhein
westfalen eine spannende konstellation
und wir wollen uns jetzt hier einmal die
fdp vor knüpfen in unserer runde mit
ulrike herrmann der publizistin mit hans
uli juristin kolumnisten und mit marcel
ute ja darf ich sagen den parteien dem
politiker kritiker hier der selbst
politiker war im abgeordnetenhaus von
berlin saß wenn wir uns die fdp heute
anschauen hans uli hoeneß warum warum so
mini geschrumpft das ist ja schon der
trend das passierte denen in
schleswig-holstein schon nimmt jetzt
sieht man die kaum noch auf dieser tafel
da so klein süchtige fdp hatte während
der korona debatten jahre wer in der
korona jahre ein thema jenseits dieses
gen themas wirtschaftspolitik das war
nämlich die freiheit
also die der kampf gegen die ständige
einschränkung von grundrechten das hat
die fdp wieder stark gemacht in der
wahrnehmung erkennen viele leute die
eigentlich eher links wähler waren
verheerend sein sagt das ist die einzige
partei die dagegen aufgestanden ist die
wähl ich diesmal das aber vorbei dass
die in der wahrnehmung der menschen ist
die korona geschichte vorbei
weitestgehend und was dann übrig bleibt
wenn man nach berlin guckt und nach
düsseldorf guckt ist dass die dort die
falschen ministerien besetzen die nach
außen hin keine wirkung haben der große
schulstreit in nrw es vorbei da gibt es
keine ideologischen auseinandersetzungen
mehr die die die
steuersenkungspolitik der fdp hat dann
ein ende wenn der fdp finanzminister
ständig neue schulden macht er
dementiert sich ständig selbst und damit
ist dieser teil der politik weg und wenn
man dann noch hinguckt was die sonst
noch haben in der in der bundesregierung
sind das unauffällige ämter während die
grünen die entscheidenden ämter besetzen
und die spd die peinlichen ja das ist
der unterschied zwischen den drei
partnern die die spd ist peinlich die
grünen sind stark genau auf den
richtigen ämtern und die fdp ist nichts
mehr wert ist nichts mehr wert sagt
hansjörg ist die spd peinlich auch das
nehmen wir mit ihr aus der runde und die
fdp nichts mehr wert weil sie die
falschen ministerien halb sagt hansjörg
wyss und weil sie sich oder ihre werte
auch verraten hat in dieser corona
krisen die fdp hat schon ganz ganz lange
jedes politische rückgrat aufgegeben und
das ist genau das zentrale problem
dieser partei auch jetzt jeder ich finds
interessant wie sie gerade beschrieben
haben das die fdp eigentlich eine corona
verordnungs kritische politiker da hat
er sich wieder joachim stamp hat sich
beim kölner karneval hingestellt als
vize ministerpräsident und hat in einem
moment an dem ich nicht so mit dem
schrecken erinnere weil ich gedacht das
kann nicht ernst gemeint sein fröhlich
gesungen impft doch einfach mit
er fragt sich jeder was also was in
solchen leuten vorgeht und sie wissen
dann eben halt ganz genau dass das was
man eigentlich als markenkern der partei
erwarten würde nicht das ist was
hinterher rauskommt und die sich
zuweilen können haus sich christian
lindner zu gehen sondern muss erst mal
sagen dass das in nrw natürlich für ihn
eine katastrophe ist denn er ist ja
bekanntlich aus energie und hat er auch
lange in dem parlament gesessen doch
gute wahlergebnis das heißt ganz
offensichtlich hat lindner überhaupt
nicht gezogen jetzt noch mal was zur
corona politik also da hat natürlich
herr jörges recht die haben immer damit
ihren freiheiten haben sie stimmen
bekommen nur ist ja das problem das muss
man jetzt mal sagen kroner ist
tatsächlich ein tödliches virus und
insofern kann ich dann auch herrn stampf
verstehen wenn er im amt als vize
ministerpräsident letztlich die leute
auffordert sich impfen zu lassen nein
das kann ich verstehen weil es überhaupt
eine individuelle thematik ist und man
nicht pauschal dahin gehen kann oder der
ausgleich und politik ganz allmählich
ganz offensichtlich sind sie also ein
impfgegner ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt
irgendwie leute die die politik wieder
selbst
wir sind der auffassung dass es
selbstverständlich alle anderen wir als
good governance gewerkschaft sind der
auffassung dass es selbstverständlich
eine frage ist die individuell jeder für
sich zu behalten und dass es nicht
angehen kann dass jetzt aber in den
aufruf ist für sie schon sozusagen geht
schon überzählig in einem regierungsamt
hinstelle war aus einer reihe als bühne
im übrigen und eines der integrativen
lieder des kölner an sich kennt und
dichte auf den vermietern bist doch
nicht dann gehörst du wieder dazu dann
ist das einfach nur ein perfides
matching aller erster güte das hat
nichts damit zu tun dass das leitbild
des grundgesetzes der bürger ist der
souverän seine eigene informierte
entscheidung aber das ist sondern das
ist der versuch ein tumbes schäfchen
volk in irgendeine richtung zu drängen
das ist genau das gegenteil von dem
wofür eine liberale partei gegenteil der
fall hatten die gesellschaft zitiert die
sie gegründet hat die jetzt viele
branchen dort auch verein will unter
anderem viele pflegekräfte sind dort
auch eingetreten wahrscheinlich eben
auch die pflegekräfte gerade
ausgerechnet die dann eben im kritisch
sind das kurz zur erklärung dazu der
vorwurf die fdp hat ihre glaubwürdigkeit
völlig ganz es gibt ja einen kopf der
herausragt immer noch der die ganze
corona politik buch eingetragen das ist
wolfgang kubicki der als glaubwürdig der
ist aber der hat aber keine dunkel sehr
schnell von denen ab
bundesvorsitzende partei und er ist aber
leider nur viel zu passiven bundestags
was da ist er sofort er hat kein
ministeramt aber er hat das
repräsentiert nicht der
parteivorsitzende nicht die anderen
minister sehr viel weniger er wollte mit
kubicki nichts zu tun hat ja wieder
kämpfe ausgetragen hat sich verbündete
außerhalb der eigenen hardheim bundestag
besucht er war von anfang bis ende
glaubwürdig andere sind geschwankt mal
so und mal so geredet linden hat sich
ganz lange nicht festgelegt bis zum tag
der abstimmung weiß man doch jetzt hier
sehen kann ist dass diese ganze analyse
deswegen die stimmen kann weil wo hat
die fdp auch ganz stark verloren in
schleswig-holstein wer ist da der kopf
kubicki der seine ware
komme
ja aus hamburg das ist ein manager
meines früheren verlages das ist ein
manager ein kühler manager der gewinnt
keiner wahl ausgeschlossen aber da hatte
lüthi nicht da hat die fdp jetzt ihre
werte verraten hat die ihre
glaubwürdigkeit verloren da eben meine
was schon stimmt ist dass die fdp so
zusagen beim kroner thema so getan hat
als wäre sie fc laiz nicht also auch
immer so freiheit freiheit gut drauf fds
für die freiheit
die die zentrale argumentation van gaal
gesagt dass die fdp den
freiheitsgedanken vertreten hat in der
korona zeit das wäre bitter in der stadt
auf den ideen also in kleinen die eine
konsequente politik gefragt ja aber darf
man das doch mal was sagen zum thema
freiheit dass man da jetzt hier
plötzlich das neue thema in unserer
sendung zu sein ich würde einfach ganz
ohne
die freiheit auf der zu überlassen das
wäre mir ganz unangenehm
von mir aus was mir wichtig ist das
würde ich auch gerne loswerden des
corona virus verschwindet nicht sondern
es kommt im herbst wieder 2,7 millionen
menschen über 60 sind nicht geimpft die
sind alle gefährdet das heißt weil diese
ganzen leute sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen werden wir im herbst wieder ein
lock down haben klein soll sind mein
schwarzes loch natur leider die wahrheit
und deswegen ist das nicht eingehalten
wird jede kausalität in die
interessierten und deswegen ist es auch
nicht so dass wenn ich sage ich bin
wichtig impfen lassen was nur eine nur
eine entscheidung für mich ist sondern
die leute die sich nicht impfen lassen
werden erzwingen dass der rest der
bevölkerung das sind über 60 millionen
was wir machen sollten wir haben sagen
also wir haben doch inzwischen alle
gelernt dass selbst die geimpften die
dreimalige impfung auf der
intensivstation liegen weil sie die die
infektion gekriegt habe da dass sie
andere anstecken das wollten sie ja gar
nicht mehr
wissen wir doch ist wirtschaftlich aber
schätzen einen nur selbst
bestimmen
aber ich möchte noch die frage mit geben
einmal dann stimmt was karl lauterbach
sagt aus ihrer sicht die haben ja schon
zitiert in der sendung hat mit ihren
sparen darüber gesprochen der jetzt in
der rheinischen post sagt die cdu ist
damit run schuld weil sie die
impfpflicht mit verhindert hat dass
jetzt mehr leute wieder an corona
sterben werden ja das ist so was
natürlich weil es ist das was herr
jörges sagt stimmt wenn man drei mal
vier mal geimpft ist kann man sich auch
anstecken aber die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass man auf der intensiv- und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man auf der
intensivstation landet ist viel geringer
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man julia
wie kommen sie denn darauf
wenn man wenn man kann andere anstecken
aber die phase in der man ansteckend ist
viel geringer die virenlast viel
geringer dh die einzige möglichkeit den
virus zu bekämpfen ist dass sich alle
impfen lassen vollkommene uns alte sie
liefert auf jeden fall wieder wieder und
immer immer wenn wir hoffen dass sie nie
wieder emotionen als wenn sie
wiederkommt möchte ich sie nicht noch
mal mit karl lauterbach ein leben lang
soll bitte eine etwas kühlere nicht wenn
sie die wahl hätten wir waren aber
gerade die ja nicht minister ich will
dann will ich eine frau in diesem amt
haben die als ärztin ist und dann etwas
schnitt einmal weil jetzt ist wolfgang
kubicki bei uns und überlangen hat ja
die runde gerade unglücklicherweise
schon gesprochen während er noch gar
nicht da so hat mich belogen jetzt
wolfgang den ausnahmen der gerade ein
dickes lob bekommen hier hat in der
runde obwohl ihre fdp heute so
abgeschmiert ist herr kubicki nämlich
hansjörg es hat gesagt das ist der
letzte der das fähnchen in der fdp davon
freiheit noch hochgehalten hat in den
letzten monaten ansonsten wurde hier in
der runde geäußert das geschieht der fdp
heute abend völlig recht die hat nämlich
ja teilweise ihre werte verraten
die hat die glaubwürdigkeit verraten
verloren
ja was soll ich dazu sagen herr jörges
ist ein brillanter analytiker aber ich
würde diese aussage nicht teilen dass
die fdp ihre werte verraten hat
möglicherweise ist das öffentliche
bewusstsein nicht ganze durchgedrungen
aber noch einmal das was in nordrhein
westfalen fast jedes energien schleswig
holstein hat überwiegend landespolitisch
grundlagen meine partei muss sich die
frage stellen warum wir wirklich über
60-jährigen so massiv eingebrochen sind
bei den wahlen das ist ja ein
strukturproblem und da müssen wir dran
gehen ist uns nützen 15 prozent oder 18
prozent bei den jeweiligen jungen leuten
nichts wenn die älteren menschen uns
nicht mehr wählen das ist die größte
wählergruppe und wir müssen da an uns
selbst noch arbeiten aber dass so ein
landtagswahlergebnis immer nur gründe im
land hat das ist ja auch ein stück weit
eine floskel an so einem abend herr
kubicki jetzt ist das die zweite bittere
niederlage heute kratzen sie sich gerade
noch so rüber wahrscheinlich über die
fünf-prozent-hürde werden sie trotzdem
anspruch erheben dort zu regieren also
mit der spd und mit den grünen wollen
sie eine ampel in nrw
ich selbst will das nicht denn es gilt
der grundsatz dass in staatlich landes
werden in eigener hoheit ohne ist der
bund sich einmischt ich war selbst stets
deutschland derjenige der sich gewehrt
hat dagegen dass wir aus berlin aus bonn
damals entsprechend informationen halten
wir uns zu weit
aber ich vermute dass zunächst erstmal
die wahlgewinner diejenigen die also
heraus man gute ergebnisse erzielt haben
gespräche aufnehmen werden und dann wird
man weitersehen noch kennen wäre das
endgültige das vorläufige amtliche
endergebnis nicht ich vermute mal wenn
es für rot-grün reichen wird wird
rot-grün westfalen installiert werden
und ansonsten wird er auch schwarz-grün
hinauslaufen hier sind momentan nicht
diejenigen die sich gedacht aber machen
müssen in welcher konstellation künftige
aufgabe ist vor allem politik macht ja
das sind relativ klare worte auch ganz
klar gesagt sie sind ein wahlverlierer
heute
ich habe diese frage hier ist ein
bisschen laut dieses recht verstanden
können sie freundlicherweise wiederholen
ja mach ich freundlicherweise sind sie
heute wahlverlierer ganz klar
mein heutiger abend wird so aussehen
dass ich meine enttäuschung versuche zu
kompensieren und ich hoffe dann auch
bessere zeiten denn eins ist klar
politik ist wie ein paradoxon manche
brauchen wieder runter es gibt bessere
tage und schlechte tage nicht nur bei
uns sondern auch bei einen anderen
beteiligten und ich kann nur dringend
davor warnen zu glauben dass ein
niederschlag für die fdp unser aus
bedeuten würde wir kippen damit nicht
aus den puschen wie kompensiert volk an
kubicki
wie ich das kompensiere ich gehe jetzt
was essen und ich gehe dann
logischerweise dabei auch ein wasser
trinken
letzte frage herr kubicki weil eben ja
viele glauben dass das doch irgendwie
was mit dem bund zu tun hat die
befürchtung wurde ja auch in der runde
geäußert hansjörg wyss hat gesagt die
falschen ministerposten hat sich die fdp
gekrallt im moment warum sind sie
derjenige diejenige partei die da am
meisten unter dem regieren leiden es
regieren doch schlechter als sie gedacht
haben
ich glaube noch einmal um new york ist
wirklich einfach die analytiker aber
etwas länger nachdenken hilft auch
weiter ich glaube und ich weiß dass
viele unserer wähler nach wie vor mit
der fdp in eine ampel auf bundesebene
etwas fremde hin und es braucht eine
gewisse zeit um hier euren anpassung
große sehr bei zu führen und wir wissen
ich weiß es jedenfalls auch ein uli
hoeneß weiß es auch die bedingung für
ein gutes wahlergebnis wahrnehmbarkeit
und gerade in den ländern nordrhein
westfalen und auch schleswig holstein
war die wahrnehmung unserer dortigen
regierungsbeteiligung zwar vorhanden
aber suboptimal das hätte man durchaus
noch steigern können dann hätten wir
auch ein anderes ergebnis und ich glaube
schon dass die frage wer für eine
landesregierung wünscht sich holstein
wie auch noch auszahlen auch viele
wählerinnen und wähler von uns dazu
gebracht hat anders zu wählen als uns zu
wählen weil sie eine bestimmte richtung
wollten und nicht mehr im kopf hatten
dass sie damit auch gleichzeitig die fdp
sprechen dank an wolfgang kubicki der
jetzt in diesem moment anfängt das
wahlergebnis zu kompensieren für sich
diese wahlniederlage danke herzlich für
das gespräch hier
glas wasser ein solides der brillanter
analytiker hat verstanden dass es sich
hier möglicherweise doch in weiß oder
rotwein handeln könnte marcel luthe bei
uns in der runde werden wir im moment
sind das auch die lehren aus schleswig
holstein und nordrhein westfalen
möglicherweise schlecht regiert kann
also ich glaube das ist doch ein
deutlich zentrales problem ist wolfgang
kubicki hat ja ihre analyse kompetenz
gelobt er dabei selbst für mich sehr
überraschend 2013 eine tolle analyse
getroffen damals formuliert und da
scheint jetzt weg zu sein die fdp hat
als marke generell verschissen zitat
wolfgang kubicki 2013 und daraus hat man
versucht den marken-relaunch zu
veranstalten und zwar tatsächlich mit
denen mit den mitteln einer ganz
klassischen werbeagentur und wenn ich
politik tatsächlich als zu verkaufen das
produkt begreife und so unfassbar
unauthentisch werde dass ich auf jede
kleine umfrage chile und im zweifel eben
halt mal wieder um kippe dann kann ich
nicht erwarten dass die leute mir
zutrauen in irgendeiner frage haltung zu
beweisen und dieses normal das was
gerade in dieser corona politik
vertreten wurde von wir auch im stand
auf der einen seite und wolfgang kubicki
auf der anderen seite habe eben halt
einfach dazu geführt dass die leute
nicht wussten was sie mit einer fdp
bekommen und das zieht sich durch alle
an anfragen eben auch und das wird
natürlich nicht honoriert werden wir
nicht ausreichend gut regiert im moment
hans-ulrich willen mal einen anderen
aspekt damit reinbringen wir reden haben
uns angewöhnt immer über programme zu
reden und was sie so vorhaben und
ankündigen usw der persönliche faktor
ist ja im endeffekt immer noch der
entscheidende herzlich also und welche
leute stellen die auf wie viel vertrauen
können die mobilisieren sind die
authentisch der herr wüst ist nicht
authentisch nach meiner wahrnehmung her
kommt man ja gut kathi noch weniger
warum nicht entwicklers ist ein kühler
geschäftsführer eines
wirtschaftsverbandes und mehr nicht und
herr kutschaty ist ein stellvertretender
rektor einer grundschule das ist das
niveau das die beiden haben und die
wollen ministerpräsident des größten
bundeslandes werden so sehe ich das
tschuldigung ja so sehe ich das sage ich
auch keiner von den beiden würde je
kanzler werden davon bin ich auch bereit
ist überzeugt es gibt im moment nur in
den grünen da haben sie völlig recht ein
paar leute die charisma haben ich habe
mich mehrfach in den letzten wochen bei
dem gedanken erwischt dass ich gesagt
habe ja gar nicht schlecht gewesen
berbalk kanzlerin geworden wäre und
fangen ist es so wie da war mir schon
gebrauchen grünen herr jörges warum ist
das so warum schaffen das die grünen sie
haben gerade gesagt die haben oder frau
herrmann hat das gesagt die haben
meistens mehr talentierte
persönlichkeiten als die plätze haben
bei den anderen parteien sahen das
meistens umgekehrt warum ist das bei den
grünen zu gehen bei den grünen
diejenigen hin die wirklich was
verändern wollen das ernst meinen und
bei den anderen sind die die irgendwo
anders hause geflogen habe nichts
anderes haben vielleicht werden sie es
nicht mehr lange sein aber die waren die
offenerer partei da konnten leute
reingehen die die nun gar nicht mal
karriere machen wollten sondern eine
offene diskussionskultur haben wollten
wo du alles beantragen bereden usw
contest während du wenn die anderen
parteien gekommen bist bist du irgendwie
da bist du in ein gatter rhein geschickt
worden da musst du dich jetzt bewegen
und bestimmt über bestimmte fragen reden
wir nicht die haben wir schon 956
geklärt und arbeitern
es gibt eine ganz klare hierarchien den
anderen parteien und das ist bei den
grünen gysi ließ abgehalten in die
politik zum beispiel zu gehen sich das
selber zu engagieren weil es ist ja
schon reizvoll ein also wenn sie mich
jetzt fragen warum ich nicht in der
politik bin dann liegt das unter anderem
daran dass
ich jetzt journalismus interessanter
finde weil das machen wir jetzt hier
auch gerade man kann bewerten wie basso
wissen man kann wissen genau ja und das
ist ein beruf wo man analysiert und
politik ist jetzt eine völlig andere
aufgabe nämlich letztlich ist es ja so
dass man umsetzen soll was der wähler
werden und zwar unabhängig davon ob das
sich mit seinen seinen eigenen analysen
deckt muss man ja irgendwie gucken das
als stimmenkönig großer wir glaube ich
dass ich anders also im unterschied zu
den beiden glaube ich ja immer noch dass
die demokratie im kern funktioniere und
dass man dass man als politiker also
alle politiker die ich getroffen habe
haben selber nie das gefühl dass sie
macht haben also die bürger denken dass
immer die haben ganz viel macht aber die
wahrnehmung der politiker ist umgekehrt
habe ich immer das gefühl wir müssen das
machen was die wähler wollen was die
umfragen sagen und so weiter die fühlen
sich gedrängt und die eigentliche
freiheit ist im journalismus großer
widerspruch
natürlich ist es gibt kein imperatives
mandat es gibt auch nicht den auftrag
den der wähler anhand von umfragen
seinem abgeordneten erteilt sondern es
werden abgeordnete gewählt die wenn sie
denn ihr gewissen benutzende eine mehr
der andere weniger nach diesem gewissen
jeweils mit ihrem eigenen kenntnisstand
eine sache entscheidung treffen sollen
und das problem der demokratie in diesem
lande gegenseitig ist dass die
allerwenigsten kollegen das tatsächlich
machen sondern die überlassen die
entscheidung in vielen fragen einem
fraktionsvorstand wir haben es bei der
debatte zur allgemeinen impfpflicht
tatsächlich mal anders gesehen das war
für mich auch eine wirkliche sternstunde
insoweit dass sie über die fraktionen
hinweg
sachargumente ausgetauscht haben und
tatsächlich eben transparenz ist das
richtige stichwort herr luthe wir haben
nämlich jetzt bei uns bei bild live
zugeschaltet aus düsseldorf karl
lauterbach ein mann also der macht hat
der minister ist hier in berlin und der
herr lauterbach sich heute als
wahlverlierer fühlt fühlen muss
ja das ist tatsächlich so guten abend
wir haben die wahl klar verloren das ist
traurig dass eine wahl ziel wurde
erreicht nämlich schwarz gelb abzulösen
aber wir haben nicht ausreichend
mobilisieren können um für die eigenen
inhalte genug also wähler also an die
urne zu bringen das ist eine große
enttäuschung alles andere wäre falsch
das muss man einräumen trotzdem über
monate hinweg war also rot grün das
wunschbündnis der bewohner hier in
nordrhein westfalen der wähler
vielleicht reicht es am ende ja doch
noch für diese möglichkeit das ist die
einzige hoffnung die ich noch in den
abend hinein tage glückwunsch an die
grünen in ganz besondere art und weise
haben einen fantastischen wahlkampf
gemacht und haben überzeugen können
glückwunsch auch an die union die union
hat es zum schluss geschafft zu
mobilisieren zulasten der fdp und damit
sind wir konfrontiert sie sagen ganz
klar wahlverlierer ist das dann
moralisch trotzdem regieren zu wollen
das ist ja keine frage der moral sondern
eine frage der inhalte wenn es zum
beispiel so wäre das also die grünen und
die union nicht zusammen kämen weil die
grünen haben das großartige wahlergebnis
ja auch bekommen weil sie gegen die
inhalte der union wahlkampf gemacht
haben also wenn schwarz-grün nicht
zusammenkommt dann wäre die inhaltliche
schnittmenge bei also rot grün natürlich
viel größer übrigens auch eine andere
viel größer somit also moralisch
ist das auf jeden fall wenn man für
seine inhalte auch nach der wahl noch
kämpft und eine solche regierung könnte
ja noch zustande kommen aber wie gesagt
es gehört dem mut dazu man kann so etwas
jetzt nicht verlangen sondern man muss
abwarten richtig entwickelt von der
landtagswahl können die
spitzenkandidaten im land mehr
entscheiden ob sie den rückenwind aus
berlin nutzen wollen ob sie dann kanzler
zum beispiel mit auf dem plakat haben
wollen oder nicht in dem fall hat die
spd entschieden jahr wollen wir wollen
den olaf scholz mittel auf dem plakat
haben und wir wollen den so oft wie
möglich auf der bühne haben hat nicht
funktioniert
ob das wirklich der grund ist das wage
ich zu bezweifeln war es waren ja im
wesentlichen landespolitische themen die
bestimmt haben schauen sie sich das
ergebnis der fdp an die schulpolitik
hier in nrw hatte
die fdp aber sich linke nicht ab ich
glaube das ist eine inhaltlich zu
treffende analyse dass also in der
schulpolitik der fdp quasi ihr ende
gesehen hat bundespolitische themen
haben auch eine rolle gespielt dass gar
keine frage aber olaf scholz macht halt
eine sehr konsequente
und aus meiner sicht auch richtige
ukraine und moskau politik die es nicht
immer populistisch das ist auch nicht
immer in ihrem blatt vielleicht dass der
gewünschte weg aber er will die
bevölkerung nicht gefährden will aber
trotzdem eine klare kante gegen russland
zeigen wir sind nachts in den
vereinigten staaten sind wir dass da
etwas verlässlich die meisten waffen zum
beispiel liefert aber wir wollen nicht
ins risiko gehen und was ich an der
politik schätze die wir aus ampel hier
machen wo du hast alles angefangen wir
wollen nicht für populistische kurse
geländegewinne bei umfragen die
bevölkerung gefährden wenn das so stimmt
stellt sich ja noch mehr die frage warum
es kein kanzlerbonus gibt also wenn das
stimmt dass aus der sicht der
bevölkerung der olaf scholz komplett den
richtigen kurs macht ist ja noch ein
größeres fragezeichen warum gibt es dann
kein kanzlerbonus
ob es keinen kanzlerbonus gegeben hat
das werden die analysen zeigen die haben
weder sie noch ich jetzt vorliegen das
muss man auswerten aber die hoffnung
jetzt folgen die grenzen kann ist ganz
einfach da brauchen wir gar keine
analysen wenn es ein kanzlerbonus gäbe
hätte die spd heute überragen die wahl
gewonnen weil bei der bundestagswahl war
die ganze nrw katho
die niederlage also die niederlage muss
ja analysiert werden welche rolle da der
kanzler gespielt hat wissen sie nicht
das weiß ich nicht da kommen auch andere
aspekte noch hinzu habe ich will so viel
nochmal in den vordergrund stellen wenn
es darum geht also abzuwägen ist man
populistisch oder also schützt man die
bevölkerung geht konsequent aber nicht
risiko also
risikobehaftet vor dann ist das der
richtige weg also wir haben als ampel
hier aus meiner sicht verantwortungsvoll
gehandelt davon haben über das auch die
grünen profitiert wir haben eine
gemeinsame politik hier vorgetragen und
somit also muss man hier die nerven
behalten im moment profitieren die
grünen in der ampel das können aber bald
auch wieder wie er sagen zum beispiel
bei der niedersachsenwahl kann es ganz
anders aussehen aber dass auch die fdp
in derart plötzlich wieder gut erholen
kann daher das kann man jetzt nicht also
dass davon nicht überinterpretieren
wollen den kanzler marlowes erstmal noch
in den analysen suchen anschließend in
den nächsten tagen und wochen arbeitet
dann suchen wir doch vielleicht ein
lauterbach mal los bei dieser wahl in
nordrhein westfalen also wie groß es
ihre schuld mit der in den sand
gesetzten impfpflicht die sehr unbedingt
wollen wo sie den kanzler auch ein stück
weit rein getrieben haben mit dem
quarantäne chaos und so weiter also wie
viel es ihre schuld
es gibt kein quarantäne chaos sondern
also die isolation pflicht ist ja
geblieben und damit haben wir uns
durchgesetzt und also ich hab den
bundeskanzler auch nicht also in die
impfpflicht also getrieben sondern er
hat von sich aus schon bevor wir die
koalition gebildet haben hat er die
endlich für richtig gefunden da waren
wir einer meinung da will ich immer der
gleichen meinung wie olaf chance gewesen
ich glaube nicht dass die also pandemie
politik hier das wahl ergebnis negativ
beeinflusst hat ich hab selbst also hier
im wahlkampf viel zustimmung erfahren
also dass also begegnet mir jeden tag
auf den straßen ich bin auch kein
unbeliebte also minister auch bei ihren
eigenen und umfragen übrigens nicht ich
das so sagen darf somit und übrigens
wenn jemand von der pandemie politik
tatsächlich also nachteile erlebt hat
dann war ist tatsächlich die fdp ich bin
nicht sicher ob es der fdp geworden ist
und da hat wenige tage vor der wahl die
masken pflicht also weg nehmen zu wollen
in den flugzeugen oder im op en v das
sind maßnahmen dann merkt der bürger
hier will man populistisch noch mal kurz
vor der wahl einen raushauen aber die
bevölkerung will eine konsequente
schützende corona polit also die korona
politik hat keine rolle gespielt im
wahlkampf und hat dann doch eine rolle
gespielt damit dass nämlich das fdp
wahlergebnis zu erklären sagt karl
lauterbach eine frage noch weil die hier
gerade in der runde auch schon aufkam
sie haben
nämlich nein lassen sie mich kurz ich
lasse nämlich kurz korrigieren ich habe
gesagt dass die pandemie collette
politik keine große rolle gespielt hat
beim schlechten wahlergebnis der spd ob
es bei der fdp anders war das habe ich
zur debatte stehe somit konstruieren sie
kann den scheinbaren widerspruch also
dass gehen wir zu schnell zu ihrem satz
in der rheinischen post herr lauterbach
sie haben sehr habe ich ausgeteilt gegen
die cdu und sie haben diese sätze gesagt
die impfpflicht hätte alles einfacher
gemacht das wissen wir dass das ihre
position ist die union trägt die schuld
wenn die impflücken zu vermeidbaren
toten und beschränkungen führt nehmen
sie das zurück
nein wieso sollte ich das so bleibt
nehmen das stimmt ja auch also wir
hätten wenn die union also mitgemacht
hätte im deutschen bundestag und hätte
die gewissensfrage tatsächlich
zugelassen hätte das nicht zu einer
fraktions abstimmung im ausschuss war es
ja jeder dann hätten wir die eben
pflicht durch bekommen oder die
wahrscheinlichkeit wäre sehr hoch
gewesen alle also ministerpräsidenten
wollten dass die mehrheit der
bevölkerung wollte dass alle
vernünftigen wissenschaftler wollen dass
ein paar ausnahmen aus an hier also
nicht mitgezählt also somit die
impfpflicht hätte uns geholfen und wir
werden natürlich im herbst also probleme
haben die wir ohne die impfpflicht also
jetzt bekommen und sonst nicht also
gehabt hätten hätten wir die endlich
durchsetzen können wir uns das erspart
geblieben darauf habe ich hingewiesen
das ist weder falsch noch also
unangenehm man muss ross und reiter sie
haben die cdu ganz offen die schuld für
künftige tote zugeschoben das ist schon
ein krasser vorwurf nehmen wir trotzdem
mit ihrer erklärung dazu r lauterbach
danke an diesem wahlabend zu ihnen nach
düsseldorf letzte frage hier in der
runde wir haben gerade schon über das
lauterbach zitat hier diskutiert letztes
ganz kurzes fazit jeder mit 1 2 sätzen
aus diesem wahlsonntag was nehmen wir
mit hans jörg s
ich nehme mit dass die spd an mehreren
schauplätzen deutschland sowohl im bund
als auch in den ländern schwach ist
schlechtes personal hat programmatisch
verwirrt ist nicht richtig geführt wird
durch den kanzlern und dass die
kleineren parteien aus jeweils
unterschiedlichen gründen zum teil
historisch abgemeldet sind die linke die
afd ist auf dem wege dahin historisch
abgemeldet zu sein und die fdp muss
wieder um ihre existenz kämpfen weil sie
wieder dabei ist wirtschaftspartei zu
werden das funktioniert nicht was luther
hat sie dieser art weniger verdrossen
gestimmt als bisher oder sind sie noch
verdrossen naja die analyse kann ich im
wesentlichen teil nur alleine bei der
fdp nicht das problem ist dass die fdp
einmal mehr leider bewiesen hat dass ihr
das politische rückgrat fehlt eine linie
konsequent zu vertreten und das
enttäuscht die menschen insgesamt sehen
wir eines in der tat die linke hat
deutlich verloren spielt im westen
überhaupt gar keine rolle mehr die afg
hat meines erachtens auch ihr
historisches zeitfenster dass ihr mann
hatte eine alternative anzubieten zu
irgendetwas vollständig verloren sie
kann jetzt gerade noch überleben aber
ich glaube das wird sich eben halt jetzt
auch auf sicht erledigen und die kern es
hälst du nicht war jetzt in der tat die
interessante dialektik von herr
lauterbach der einerseits als im übrigen
eines der bekanntesten gesichter dieser
koalition keinerlei verantwortung bei
sich sieht in der tat die hat er
zurückgewiesen oder ricke herrmann hat
das schlusswort hierbei bild live was
nehmen sie mit aus diesem wahlsonntag
also ich finde das jetzt sozusagen die
rolle der spd zu negativ und so für sie
miss tisch gesehen wird also erstens
herr lauterbach hat völlig recht wenn er
sagt dass er bei der bevölkerung sehr
beliebt ist das zeigen auch die umfragen
zweitens immer beides bei ihm viele
finden den toll und köln aber auf jeden
fall ist er so ist er sehr beliebt und
auch sehr markant und ist ein gesicht
dieser regierung und das auf keinen fall
schadet und natürlich ist er hat herr
lauterbach recht wenn er sagt dass zum
beispiel wenn der niedersachsenwahl
kommt die steht ja noch an und es sieht
doch so aus dass der amtsinhaber heil da
auch gewinnt von der spd denn diese
ganze debatte und die spd gewinnt ja nie
in irgendeinem land das ist dann schon
wieder vorbei ist sondern man kann
eigentlich sagen dass sozusagen die
reihenfolge der wahlen für die spd etwas
ungünstig war hätte jetzt nicht
nrw gewählt sondern sagen wir mal das
saarland wo frau rehlinger 43 prozent
bekommen hat als amtsinhaberin dann
hätten alle gesagt ja die spd im aufwind
das heißt man darf letztlich den fehler
nicht machen dass man irgendwelche
landesergebnisse auf die
bundestagswahlen hatte doch immer
betreuen kein spaß machen jede story
aber es ist natürlich so ein bisschen
quatschen vielen dank für die lebendige
diskussion heute ulrike herrmann hans
uli engers und marcel ute das waren die
richtigen fragen an diesem spannenden
wahlsonntag den wir hier gleich noch
einmal in aller ruhe für sie
zusammenfassend auf den punkt hierbei
bild live ganz kurz auf also dann zurück
hier
[Musik]